Allah herkese Merhabalar Hepiniz hoş
geldiniz Çok güzel görünüyorsunuz çok
büyük bir kalabalıkla aynı sahnede
gibiyim Ben bunu da dönen Balıkesir
Kepsut 125. Yıl Ortaokulu etmeyin böyle
12 oğlum sizlere son sekiz yılını yani
Hayatın yükünü yakaladım küllerinden
Doğuş hikayesini anlatacağım
tamamlamadan önce bir kaç nokta demek
istiyorum kişisel başarılar daha çok
grupla ilgili çalışmaların projelerini
başarılarımı anlatacağım yine birçok
kişi dinlenmesinde izlemişsinizdir
aditasyon yerine kadar başka noktaları
gitmemiz açısından tüm gerçekliğiyle o
yaşanmışlığı o hayatı vermeye
çalışacağım yine en başından daha
yaşadık zorluklar nelerdi varsayımlar
çıktılar sonuçlar hepsini Teker teker ne
Hastane sürenizin yettiği kadarıyla
Anlatmaya çalışacağım Herkese iyi
seyirler Ben Balıkesir'in en küçük
ilçelerinden biri olan kırsal Birincide
ya
İyi günler geldim eğitim-öğretimi tuz
okulda tamamladım Maddi manevi zorluklar
yaşadık ve bizim için en zorunda Tabii
ki anne karnındayken daha henüz bir Anne
karnım eve babam uçak kazası sonucu
kalemlik Annem alt birlikte yaşadık we6
ikinci evliliğini Yaptı annem fakat
şefkatle çok iyi geldik huzurlarınızda
teşekkür ediyorum Allah razı olsun ve
ardından gelen küçük kız karışımından
yapmış sürdürüyoruz O zamanlar
başlamıştım sorgulamaya düşünmeye dedim
ki bize bu kadar iyilik yapan bizim
okumamız için elimden gelenin fazlasını
gösteren bir baba için ben de cihaz
kalamazdım şey yapmak zorunda
hissediyorsun kendime dedim ki ilk önce
kız kardeşinden başlayacak ve onun
yerleri gelmesi için elimden gelenin
fazlasını yapacak ve sonra tüm insanlar
gerekir Çünkü dünyaya bağlı
paylaşımlarımı yardımlarını iliklerimi
projelerin çalışma
bu sunmak için yola koymuştum tabi
öğretmen olmalıydım ve müzik öğretmen
olmalıyım Çünkü insan bunu ilmek ilik
işlemek istiyorum ve müzikle uğraşan
kişiden kültür beklemez onun ruhu
temizlenmiştir alınmıştır kız karşında
ben de müzik öğretmeni olmuştuk
hayallerinin artık bir adım iki adresine
geçmiştik dört yıl çalıştıktan sonra
yatılı okul maceram başladı oraya
tanesinde çıktım Yatılı okulda çalışmak
köy okulunda çalışmak doğuda belde köy
değil değil çalışmak Yani eğer kazanmak
istiyorsanız bunda bir araya gelmek
istiyorsunuz çok önemli öğretmenlik için
ve Ben bunların hepsini yaşadım kendimi
olduğunu hissediyordu bahsetmek
istiyorum öğrencilerimiz 25ta köyünden
bizim Okulumuz geliyorlar 11 32 saat
uzaktalar 27 çalışanlar
bu düşenler annesi babası ayrı olanlar
vefat edenler bırakıp gidenler daha
küçük yaşta derisini Nesine Bakmak
zorunda kalan öğrencilerimiz var Baran
tabi müzikten bir haberler ver onlar
için en devasa en görkemli sunma blok
futbolu Bazıları için köylerde okul yok
birleştirme Sultan dokuyorlar en az 8-10
tane öğretmen değişik yaşamışlar bu
Maddi manevi olduğu içerisindeler
sosyo-ekonomik durumlar çok düşük
hayvancılık ve tarımla uğraşıyor yani
tam dezavantajlı bir bölgedeyiz doğru da
Bunlar mevcut batıda maalesef mevcut ve
afiyet okuma geldim fakat ne
biliyorsunuz var ne de bir müzik
sınıfımız var Bir şeylerin değişmesine
gelişmesi gerekiyordu imkansızlıklara
Çaresiz Ben mucizeleri olur bugün yani
var ise unutma vardır demektir
düşüncelerini benimsedik ve Bir hafta
boyunca dedim ki öğrencilerime çocuklar
hayallerimiz var neler dedim yolla
ve diğer yüzmesini öğrenmek denizi
görmek Balıkçı ile dışarı çıkmak
asansörün Mac ürünleri kullanmak
televizyonlara çıkmaya yurtdışına gitme
uçağa binmek gibi hayalleri vardı Ben
hepsini küçük not defterime Buket
tembelliğim hafızamı aldım Acaba
hangilerinin gerçekleştirilecektir ve
yolculuğumuz başladı tabi esmanızı yok
demiştim lüks sınıfımızda yok Bir gün
babamın Züccaciye dükkanına gittim
oradaki biraz paralar gözüme ilişti
dedim ki Tamam Bunlar bizim en sonunda
olabilir hemen kız kardeşimle
istişareler yaptık okulumuza gittik 5
oran seçtim ve yerde sırada Masada öyle
nasıl teröristler di birinci küçük
gördüm derken baktım birden motifler
cümleler kompozisyonlar içinde oluşmaya
başladı ve çok ayette Biz haline geldi
duyduk ki Cumhurbaşkanlığı Senfoni
Orkestrası ulusal salgılar pastel varmış
Hemen başvurumuzu yaptık binlerce
başvuru arasından seçildi qu
Ben de bir ilki gerçekleştirerek
iki grup arasında girdik ve Ankara'ya
Yolculuk başladı tabi sponsorlar bulduk
bir şeyler topluyoruz kendi aramızda
Çünkü dediğim gibi maddi imkansızlıklar
var Orada büyük bir ilgi alaka alıyorduk
tabi Cumhurbaşkanlığı Senfoni Orkestrası
Türkiye en güzel sahnesi ayakta akşamlık
ne oradan Kafanı salla çıkmıştım Seriye
bu şekilde gelme gidip buraya herkes
devasa ve görkemli gelmişler bakteriler
hedefler Aslında okullarda sadece lastik
mi ve kız kardeşimde ki Abi iki sene
şöyle yapalım derme çatma onlardan bir
Ritim Grubu kuralım kendimize güncelle
yenildim çok hoşuma gitti Fikir İbrahim
amca getirelim bir hafta sonu hiçbir
amca Sevim teyze Sen ne zaman getirelim
bir daha sonra Teşekkürler Bizden de bir
şeyler ekledik ve 5 olan sayının 9'a
çıkarttık yeni kompozisyon ödüyoruz 23
bu bölümü çalışıyoruz ve artık
görüntümüz artmaya başladı yerelde de
gazetelerde Efendim küçük televizyon
programlarında artık Balıkesir'in yani
dışına çıkamamıştır alıyoruz yani
genelde doğru bir geçiş vardı tekrar
onlarla yine aynı aynı aynı ilgi ve
alaka ve oradan tekrar kafamız sağlıyor
açıktı dedim ki seneye yakışıklı
olmayacak artık bağımsız bir çalışma
alanı kurmamız gerekiyor olması
gerekiyor niye üst kattaki video pes
Atatürk üretemiyoruz çalışamıyoruz
Duydum ki bir buçuk kendisi Güney
Marmara Kalkınma Ajansı proje çağırsın
çıkmış Bizim daha yeni haberimiz olmuş
son 4
Az önce süresi bitmesine hemen olmayan
bir proje ki buluşuruz matematik
öğretmeni Arkadaşlar şöyle yapalım böyle
yapalım dördünüz var olmuyorum derken
orada sistem Yüksel vuruş Biz anlamayız
yapamayız geçmez boş uğraşmıyorum falan
filan arkadaşlar bana öğretmeye
bırakalım elimizden gelenin en iyisini
yapmaya çalışalım Takdiri ilahi yani
eksiklerimiz yapacağım sonuçları
açıklandı Kısa bir süre sonra 213 bin
lira değerindeki ve kazandık yatılı okul
ile eğitim-öğretim görünen binamızın tam
ortasına yani mm an tam ortasına
evimizin yan odası odası ymış gibi
öğrencilerimizin 24 saat önce
kendilerini özgürce ifade edebilecekleri
artık bir yerin sadece bir dünya dikkat
et başlatmış otobüs i8x 20384 metrekare
çapında çam ağacıyla tamamen kaplı
içinde 40
34 farklı tür B4 yüzeye ulaşan bir Esma
sayısıyla Güvenlik açık adresini
sahiplik bitmiş miydi Hayır asıl macera
sahip ülke için başlıyordu tekrar CS
Hastanesi'ne başvurdu ilk yıl beş
plastik bardak ile iki yıl derme çatma
uzmanlarıyla 3. yıl kendimi soğanımız
vardı artık tam bir başarıyı sevimli
artık oluşturduk hemen okula
geldiğimizde kurslarımıza açmadık Çünkü
asıl dediğim gibi hikaye macera burada
başlıyordu herkese açalım dedik
üniversite son sınıfta okuyan altı
öğretmen adayına dahil kazansın diye Ben
de rehberlik ettim ve bağlama gitar
piyano yan flüt dersi açtık şimdi bir
kimi birkaç kurstan yaralandı okul
çıkışlarında sonlarında herkes birer
sunan değil 5 10 15 35-40 akan enstrüman
çalarlar Deniz artık Okulumuzun
oluşmuştu biz
360 ders var ama biz tüm okulunuzu
tersine yaptık aynı birkaç defa nöbetçi
olduğu günlerde ya da okul çıkışında
Öğle arasında toplanıp eylenceler müzik
dersleri bilgi yarışmaları ve oradaki
kutu biraz geçirecek birçok aktiviteden
yani paramız sağlık önce bizim projemizi
daha geliştirmek istedik dedi ki bizim
Kaç öğrenciniz var 184 öğrendi çarpı kaç
Asuman çalar dedik sayacağım 152 değer
hocam 2300 tam 3089 gibi ciddi bırakın
ulaştık ve hemen Yiğit'le eğitim-öğretim
değil ürünlerine başvurduk projemiz
Balıkesir 12 gerçekleştirerek yine hem
bölgesine öldüren bakalım ödülü bizzat
bakar mısınız ya ellerinden başarı
belgesini aldık yenilikçi öğretmen
seçmiştim ve artık Türkiye birincisi
olmuştuk zaman çok önemli kime ne ne
kadar
en çok dikkat etmeliyiz Ben zamanının
çoğunu aracını verdim kalbenben Uyan çok
rahatım Yine olsa yine yaparım Biz insan
zekasını en fazla etkisi olan ritim
yaptık çalışmalarımızı kendime ait beş
tane farklı yöntemi tekniği var Bunları
kullanarak abartı olmasın yüzde yüzü
geçen başarı oranına sahibiz o grafikler
Zaten sürekli bizim elimizde mevcut
baştan ve yani öncesi ve sonrası olmak
üzere anketler düzenliyoruz Tabii ki
öğrenciyim Kız kardeşim Eşine birlikte
üç yılda uğraştığımız kitabımız bitmek
üzere Biraz mükemmelliyetçi olduğu için
inşallah size ulaşacaktır yakın zamanda
çıkacak yine Kültür ve Turizm
bakanlığınca projemiz geçti ve belgesini
şekilde
bu Balıkesir Milli Eğitim müdürlüğünce
yapılan en yarışması en sanatsal ve
sosyal doku seçildik binlerce başvuru
arasından tüm dünyadaki yetenek Avcıları
katıldığı gereksiz 2016 yarışmasında
Türkiye birincisi yani şampiyon olduk
gençlerle artık 29 öğrencimiz güzel
Savaşı'nı kazandılar Sen niye müzik
öğretmeni olacak öğrencimiz artık var
şimdi sekiz alır çalışmamız yapıyoruz bu
dokuzuncu nesil lafı çalışıyoruz kaç
konserve olabiliriz ulusal ve
uluslararası olmak üzere iki üç yüz tam
627 konserimiz verdik Türkiye'nin ve
dünyanın dört bir tarafından davet
oluyoruz birlikte akran eğitimi
yapıyoruz kurslar veriyoruz konser
veriyoruz yine sizlerin arasından da
hani biz ile ilgili çalışma yapmak
isteyen yardım isteyen olursa bizi
ulaşabilir tüm sosyal medya araçlarından
elimizden gelenin fazlasını yapmaya
hazırız Aslı öğretmenlik 40
Evet arkadaşlar ben en arka sırada ki
adıyla Ayşe ile Ahmet'le Mehmet'le bağ
kurulamıyor saniye çıkmıyorsun
Göremiyorum ki ben biliyorum fakat
hiçbir bağımız yok der edilmesidir
öğretmenlik yani o şekilde gelişir 185
bankamatik öğretmeni değildi ki de
hiçbir zaman yapmadık yapmayacağız
yapılmamalıdır yaşam tarzı öğretmenlik
yani edilmesidir vatanını en çok seven
görevini en iyi yapandır Bizim işimiz
gücümüz bir sonucunu savaşma sebebimiz
çalışma çalışma çalışma olmalı duyuyorum
şimdi sizleri Hayaller geçmişti
biliyorsunuz Hayaller gerçekleşir
öğretmenim yani artısı var Eksi yoktur
altı tane köye gittik hem kutu
dünyamızda yerleştirdik hem Türkiye'de
cinsellik ve Türk bayrağımızı en şekilde
orada dalgalandırdı keyfel kulesinin
önüne bile Almanya Gürcistan Kazakistan
o Fransa Hollanda Belçika kendimden
Biraz önce de Balkanlar'ın YouTube mavi
süreçten dolayı ertelendi denize
götürdük öğrencimizi öğrencilerimizin
öğrenenler Balıkesir il dışına çıkanlar
Türkiye nerede sahibim dolaştık
cumhurbaşkanımızdan yani o başka bak
Başbakan Bakanlar Bir de fikirleri en
uzak dışındaki Ahmet amca kadar Ali dayı
kadar Ayşe teyze Fatma teyze kadar
konserimize sunduk ve sunmaya devam
edeceğiz keşkeleriniz var mı var Keşke
daha öğreten kişilerde tanışmasaydık
ve yine engelleri Aşk filmine Ulaş
adında iki grubumuzu kurduk engelli
öğrencimiz oluşuyor zihinsel işitme ve
bedensel engellilere engelli öğrenciler
oluşu ile şefimiz öğrenciler İstiklal
Marşı ilişkili üretiyorlar muhteşem
oluyorlar yani onları bir tebessüm
Herşey döner aynı Deniz Yıldızı'ndaki
hikaye gibi artık onun için Çok şey
değişti gidebilmek hayatını süre kala
bir ağaç mesaj atıyorum onu Dallı
Budaklı birçok Buraya su var Her
açarsanız müzik kötü olur değil mi yani
o herkesin kazanması gereken hükümler
var bu şekilde bak biz anne karnındayken
doğum yani doğumlu bir dolaşıyor kalp
atışlarını dedim ölene kadar inşallah
rapiniz hiç bozulmaz hayatını
yakalarsınız biz onlara onlar binlere
binler artık yüzbinler oluşacak biz bu
çalış
ve devam edeceğiz yani Milyonlar
milyarlar ulaşmak için ne gerekiyorsa
yapacağız çalmasını bilen öğretmene her
öğrenci bir enstrümandır sokak müstafi
yapıyoruz Hemen atıyorum proje çok
hoşuma giden ve çok özel bir proje bu
babamın 95 model bir virüs var kız
kardeşim Eşim ve 1-2 atematik bir fen
bilimleri öğretmenine yanımıza alıyoruz
öğrencilerimizin öğretmeni köy yumurtası
tatlısı ve domatesin götürüyorlar
Esma'nın üzülüyoruz geçen sene 23 gün
boyunca kuşadasın kuşadasına yaydık ders
çalışıyoruz denize giriyoruz ve
öğrencilerimizin gidiyoruz Aqua Park
piknik derken akşam şarkımız açık Sokak
müşterimize yapıyoruz olan kazandım 35
kuruş parayı da eğitim masraflarını
saflarımıza harcıyoruz çok özel bir
proje dediğim gibi İnşallah bu sene de
gideriz diye düşünüyoruz ile pandomim
sürecinde eşim Kız kardeşim ve arabamıza
binip kökü dolaştık
o öğrencilerimize tablet okuma kitabı
test kitabı enstrümanlar sürpriz hediye
paketi hazırladık yani servislerin
tebessümleri gördüğünüz gerekiyordu tabi
belirler ne yapacaklarını bilemiyorlar
bize göre eğitim-öğretimin asıl amacı
ulaşımı ulaşmaktır yani iyideki ya da
maddi durumu iyi ya da fırsat eşitliği
sağlanmış öğrencinin zaten Ve bir şeyler
var ama en uzak başına kalmış kişi
ulaşırsak ne mutlu bizlere yani onu
Aslında çıkarabilmek onu ortaya
koyabilmek de güzel ayna kelebek
etkisindeki gibi olur inşallah Yani
benim istediğim tek bir şey var En az
bir kişi hayatını kurmak yani maddi
manevi beklentimiz yok inşallah onları
bir kişinin hayatında okunup milyarları
Ulaşırız Düşünsenize milyarlarca iyilik
Yani bütün ya temizlenmiş olur diye
düşünüyorum yine müziğin birisi gücüyle
şoföründen hemşiremiz den
idarecilerimize öğretmenimizden verilir
bu Aşkımıza kadar bir müzik topluluğu
oluşturduk konser lerimizi sunduk aklını
başından masası istiyorum inanılmaz
artış oldu ikinci modda bir cimos tan25
fazla yapan öğrencimiz bursluluk kazanan
öğrencilerimiz okul birincilerimiz yine
iyi okula kazanan öğrencilerimiz ilçemiz
oyun insanın altıncı sıraya ilerledi
tabi ilçemizdeki Okulumuzdaki
öğretmenlerimize teşekkür ediyoruz
onlara karşı çok büyük yine ilçede değil
de yani sanatsal hareketlilik ortaya
çıktı bizim 1.23 sayıda ondokuzmayıs
etkinliklerimizde ki yaptığımız o
gösteriler gerçekten yönetim sistemi
üzerinde ama bunu Abartısız söylüyorum
İnşallah bir gün karşılaşırız yine çürük
Düğünümüz Körler var ne ispatladığı mı
tekrardan teori lerimiz mevcut mesela
Müzik kulağı musun gerekiyor olması
gerekiyor Geç önemli değil Herkese
olabilir Bunu kanıtladık defalarca bunu
kanıtladık
bir tek size çok teşekkür ediyorum beni
anladıkları için konuşmacı olarak
sizlere huzurları çıkardıkları için
inşallah her şey gönlünce olur ilk
varsınız Güzel günler diliyorum İnşallah
görüşmek üzere Kendinize çok iyi bakın
hoşça kalın her şey gönlünce olsun
abone ol